[Music]
i like to go to the extremes to
understand
some of the lessons we need to learn for
example i turned to the military so that
i could better understand
trust and i look to bruce deal
so i can better understand compassion
the work that he is doing at his
organization
city of refuge is nothing short of
remarkable
in fact i was so inspired by him i had
the opportunity to publish his book
trust first which i highly recommend
the experiences that bruce has had can
teach
us how to be better versions of
ourselves this
is a bit of optimism
so good to see you thanks so much for
sitting down to do this with me it's
always a pleasure to see you
great to see you thanks for the
opportunity to spend some time together
i wanted to talk to you about this idea
of giving people a second chance
you work with prostitutes and drug
addicts and
people who've often been marginalized
and forgotten in society
what i think is so profound about you
and your organization
is how sometimes the idea of giving
people a second chance
can actually be a daily occurrence
that sometimes you believe in someone
and they let you down and you have to
give them a second chance again and
again and again
all right so for many of the people that
we deal with they were born into
poverty lack of quality education they
didn't have safe and affordable housing
they were born without
forward momentum and so even though they
made a lot of bad decisions in life
where a lot of bad things have happened
to the outsider we're giving them a
second chance and
a lot of times i feel like we're giving
them their first real chance
and of course if you've only been given
one first chance
and you've got all this history with bad
things in your past
you're probably going to fail at the
first chance and so we
enter into that relationship with an
expectation
frankly that they're probably not going
to quite get it right the first time so
we need to already be prepared on the
front end
for what the second and third chance
looks like it's very much like a parent
isn't it which is when a child is young
which is ostensibly their first chance
at doing most things that they're gonna
do everything
not most things everything they're not
gonna ride a bicycle for the first time
properly they're not going to
use their knife and fork properly it's
all going to be a mess
it's not so much that we put a date on
it takes this amount of time to ride a
bicycle if you don't ride a bicycle by
this date
we're going to put you up for adoption
but rather it's a process
you hold the seat you put the training
wheels on you take one wheel off and you
fumble through it and they fall and they
get back on
and you believe in the process and
eventually every kid can ride a bicycle
is that more of what it's like yeah i
think so
i'm big on both trust the process and
trust the people
so you have to have the process first if
you just start extending second chances
without a process
as to how that should look that's going
to fail always so trust the process
trust the people i'm a father of five
daughters i'm now the grandfather of
five
grandkids two more being born in the
next couple months
and what i found in my process i'm much
more tolerant of the second generation's
failures than i was the first
generation's failures
so it's also a process for us for some
of us it's
really hard to give second or third or
fifteenth chances
but the longer we do that the more adept
we become at that
and then we start to understand that it
is a longer journey than we want it to
be intuitively one of them to hurry up
and grab it and get
it but it is a long slow process and
unless we're willing to walk with people
that have had difficulty in life
they're probably going to crash and burn
at some point because nobody was there
to prop
them up for that next chance tell me a
story of someone
who has gone through your process sure
so quickly ryan was born
in cleveland ohio abusive stepfather ran
away at 13
was recruited into a gang was in a gang
for 14 years
robbery crew all over the united states
in and out of jail
drug addiction all kind of issues moved
to atlanta because there was a contract
on his life in cleveland
ran into us the day after we met him we
moved him into our facility gave him
keys to a room
and at least seven times in the next
five years he bailed on us
went back to the streets went back to
the same life and all seven times we
went looking for him we didn't just wait
for him to come back to us
we often predicate our second chances on
whether or not that individual is
willing to return to us and apologize
for their failure
when sometimes they're willing to take
the chance and embrace what we give but
we got to go tell them
that we're willing to do that so at
least seven times we went after him
we're now 14 years into that journey his
record has been expunged seven felonies
have raised from his record
got certified as a licensed security
guard in atlanta
owns his own security company now has 35
employees
serving multiple organizations in the
city and
all of those that he's employing are
those that we're given second and third
and fourth chances to as well
how many years have you been doing this
23 years so 23 years
if you look back at yourself in your own
relationships with your wife or your
children or your friends
how has your process in working at city
of refuge changed you
so i grew up in a conservative real
tight kind of environment
my father was a minister it was great it
was great environment but i found myself
with a lot
of preconceived notions and judgments
about others based on their behavior
not based on who they are and 23 years
later i just have almost zero
judgment on the front end so i meet
somebody
and i hear their story and where i used
to judge whether or not they're a good
person to make good decisions now i just
see them as an opportunity
for us to walk with and see what the
future can be rather than judging them
on what the past has been
i think that's the biggest thing that's
happened to me is i've just chosen to
lay
down this attitude and mentality i'm
gonna judge people based on their
vocabulary or their lifestyle or
color of their skin i've just decided
those things are inappropriate
and i have to believe in them even if i
can't see
yet what i believe is there we should
all carry that advice with us
i had a conversation with dia khan
recently
and dia is a documentarian she's a
muslim woman
who spent time with white supremacists
and engaged in what i labeled extreme
listening
she took these people who hate her and
gave them a
safe space to say what they think
she gave them a space to feel heard and
she didn't fight with them
and i asked her how do you listen
without judgment she says oh no no i
judge
i do listen with judgment but i sit in
that discomfort
what you're talking about is something
entirely different and i think it's so
interesting that in both cases
the objective is to allow the other
person to feel heard
to feel like they matter in the world
exactly and when i say i don't judge
wrong is wrong and right is right so
there's some behavior
that obviously judges itself what i'm
talking about is i don't judge the
individual
for the behavior the behavior is wrong
we deal with that here
now let's deal with who you are as an
individual what led you to this place
what experiences in your life have
happened that i'm unaware of
that causes your behavior to be
something that i don't agree with
this is such a great sophisticated
thought for us to be able to disconnect
the behavior from the person one of the
things i know
when we lob insults at people very often
we mean to tack the behavior but we end
up doing is attacking the person
you're a liar versus you lied
right when you say you lied you can have
a breakthrough there
but if i say to you you're a liar i'm
now attacking who you are and you're
going to dig in
and maybe even attack me back this is
something very similar to be able to
separate
the behavior from the person to
criticize the behavior perhaps
but to allow the person to be that clean
slate that tabula rasa
yeah it's my opinion that so many people
live in a false identity
because of exactly what you're talking
about they have been labeled by others
you're a liar you're a thief you're an
addict you're this you're that
we actually try not to term the folks
that we serve by the labels everybody
else gives them so we don't necessarily
talk about the homeless we talk about
those who are
in transition right now it's amazing
what the difference makes to that
individual when you don't say hey i know
you're homeless i want to help you
if you say hey i understand you're in
transition right now
here are a couple resources that we have
for you and so sometimes it's literally
just a choice of vocabulary
that helps individuals feel like you're
not judging them you're actually giving
them a chance to be what you believe
they can be
i love this it's not that you're a thief
it's that you have stolen things
right it's not that you're a prostitute
but you have prostituted yourself
right it's a very finite and infinite
concept i'm just realizing as you're
talking about it
because to label someone is very
complete
absolutely and worse is if they start to
believe
that label they see no hope for their
future they become their label
yeah it goes to your point the infinite
game
with the folks that we serve at city
refuge it's never about today
this is always about a future that we
may never see the end of
and so we've served 23 000 people in the
last 23 years they say we serve about a
thousand unique individuals a year
i have no idea what the roi is there
simon
but i do know that 10 15 years later i
still get messages from folks that go
hey what you guys shared with me 10 12
years ago
is working now so it's not just about
the results i can see today or tomorrow
it's about an investment in somebody's
future it is the infinite game i may
never see the end of that but it's still
the right
work people are so uncomfortable with
that that to invest so much time and
energy
and not necessarily know if that is
going to be a result any time soon
well especially in the nonprofit space
where i spend most of my time
we like to call it the four impact space
for impact space that's correct
in the four impact space so much is
based on outcome-based measurements
funding is often dependent upon
outcome-based measure
getting the next contract for the
government to support you on your next
program is depending on your graduation
rates and your success rates
so the world in which we live is
programmed in such a way that you have
to have success scenarios
we've actually flipped that and my team
i just tell them all the time this is
not about success this is about
obedience
this is what we feel like we're called
to do we feel like this is our
assignment we feel like this our life's
work
so as long as we do that with passion
excellence dignity and integrity
then we are successful but if we're
driven just by the numbers i think we
get lost
in production versus productivity which
to me are two different things
i love this and it really is two things
vision
cause you have to have cause that's the
calling
and the process again i go back to that
original analogy if you're teaching a
kid how to ride a bicycle there is a
process to learn how to ride a bicycle
it starts with training wheels
and if you follow the process it 100
works but you just have to believe in
the process
so i guess that if you have a process
that has some
positive outcomes and you see that over
the course of time this does work
you tweak and tweak and tweak it becomes
the process that you're obsessed with
in other words you allow for the process
to evolve you have to
the fundamentals of learning how to ride
a bike haven't changed
but what you're doing is constantly
constantly constantly tweaking the
process to make it work better
and in this case prepare people for the
full
right here's the real truth we've had
far more failures than successes
when you deal with people that are
coming out of incarceration they're
coming out of addiction they're veterans
of ptsd they've been sexually abused
traumatized they've had zero support
system in their life
the percentages of success are always
going to be less
than the percentages of failure so again
it goes back to not measuring this
by some position that we place that they
have to be in life
it is this is the right thing to do
we've discovered the right way to do it
now you do the right thing the right way
over and over and over
yeah and what we do is we celebrate all
of the victories and we try to learn
from the failures so we don't get
dismayed by the failures although at
times that's challenge
we try to learn from the failures and
celebrate all the victories
how do we apply what you've learned to
our own lives
like how do i become a better version of
me
by learning the lessons that you've
learned because most of us aren't doing
the kind of work you're doing but we can
apply what you're learning
yeah well i think in every environment
this attitude of trying to see the best
in everybody
every day so in the business place and
corporations and our family and our
friendships
we all have failures we all have faults
everybody that i work with is going to
disappoint me at some point in time
can i look beyond that and see the good
that they are bringing to me and to our
organization and to the people we serve
so seeing the best in people i think is
really critical simon
and that's a learned skill by the way
the second thing is to speak that truth
to them
and about them out loud so saying to
people what you believe about them that
they may not even believe about
themselves
we say it to them but we also say it
about them in front of others
it's an incredible incredible dignity
giver and it's also
this belief system process that they
begin to develop in themselves when i
talk
positively about somebody in front of
their peers or in front of those that
are on the journey with them
to help them get better and how do we
learn that skill is it just practice
there's not a whole lot i pride myself
on i think i'm a good student of
observation
so what i try to do is just see what's
something this person's doing
saying or i can see in them that is not
visible
without studying them so just observing
is really critical and the more i've
practiced that over the years the more i
begin to recognize these good places
in people's lives that are covered up by
all the external things
it's sort of a mindset isn't it
absolutely complete mindset
it's kind of a choice how to approach
the day in the morning
well yeah i mean it's in embracing the
day and focusing all the positives that
might be there
with an understanding that the other
stuff's always going to be there
so it's not negating the negative it's
just saying i know that's there we'll
deal with it but here's what we have to
celebrate
yeah do you have a favorite story of
someone who's come through city of
refuge
yeah i met jake when he was 57 years old
jake was an african-american that grew
up on a plantation in south georgia as
part of a sharecropper family
so he experienced racism at the highest
level his father was an alcoholic and
abusive he tells the story of hiding in
the closet
at 11 years old why his father fired a
gun trying to kill he and his mother he
ran away from home at 11
and started crashing in a little utility
shed at a nearby golf course
met a couple of guys they started
teaching him some things he started
caddying turned out to be a great golfer
was one of the first
african-american teaching pros in golf
but fell subject to crack cocaine and
alcohol addiction
we met him in the streets living under a
bridge and jake and i just became
great friends and for the next 13 years
jake lived with us on and off times he
would sit at our table he loved my wife
he loved my daughters i loved him
i would employ jake and jake would fall
back into his addiction he would go back
to jail since his 13-year journey
we lost jake for about eight months
about four years ago
and he came back and he had been in jail
again he got arrested for some crazy
stuff
and jake always said either you'll do
the time or the time will do you and
this time the time had done jacob so his
mental health was a little off
and he was just struggling i said jake
you want to move back in he goes i can't
this can't be confined can i just sleep
in the back seat of your truck so i had
this
f-254 pickup with crew cab and i said
well sure
it's parked on the parking lot so jake
would get some meals and shower and
clothes and he would sleep in my truck
we were there together and i would see
him and we would talk and i'd give him
some work
but he just struggled to overcome life
and so one monday morning one of the
guys that works for me steve walks in
and he says hey
somebody's asleep in the backseat of
your truck but it's not jake that's a
great big guy
and so i walk out and i look in the wind
and i go you know
it's jake and he's dead yeah and jake
had died in the back seat of my truck a
couple nights before
and his body had bloated we had to call
the coroner they break the wind of the
smell of death rolls out they drag him
out in a parking lot it's just so
unceremonial
i really got hacked off simon right we'd
invested
13 years of believing and identity and
all these kind of things and at the end
of the day
jake died still not overcoming all of
his demons
but it took me a couple months to really
process and i still
come to tears about i have jake's golf
clubs and shoes sitting outside my
office door as a reminder of who we are
and what we do
but the thought struck me a couple
months after jake's death jake came home
to die
jay could have died under a bridge he
could have dived in the graveyard he
used to sleep he could have died in
prison we would have never known
we wouldn't have been able to have a
funeral for jake to recognize jake to
talk about his legacy with us
this was a place he felt loved and cared
for a place where he had been given
chance after chance after chance and
there was something inside of him i
believe
that knew life was coming to an end and
he wanted to be home
when he died and for us that's success
it didn't end like i wanted it but he
knew he was cared for and loved at the
end
and he knew that the back seat of my
truck was his
and so that's why we do what we do
it still plays that infinite game you
know that success isn't
we got you off drugs and you're now
gainfully employed and can take care of
yourself and your family
it's progress towards an ideal and as
long as there's movement
forwards and jake went on a lot of
twists and turns and a lot of speed
bumps but at the end of the day
he was further down the path when he
died than he was when he started on the
path yeah
and jake would have died 10 years
earlier if he hadn't met us yeah
if he'd have stayed in his full crack
addiction the whole time
full alcoholism the full sleeping out in
the cold weather jake would have been
dead 10 years before
and so for us it's not about whether he
ever got to this place that we dreamed
he would get to
it's that at least he had the
opportunity to get to that place
and he was closer to it at the end than
he was at the beginning
you know so much about human behavior
you've seen people at their best and
their worst
and you interact with people obviously
outside of city of refuge
and i assume some people are telling you
how to do your job sometimes
there have to be little voices that go
on in your head instead of rolling your
eyes
that you see so much opportunity
in society to learn some of the lessons
that you've learned like you look out
the wind and be like my god this country
this world would be a better place if
what's if if we did what if we learned
what
well such a big question number one if
we would stop being so selfish
it's always about us that's what
probably frustrates me more than
anything else i travel and speak in
churches and
businesses and for impact summits all
kind of things and
it always feels like everybody's there
for them
even if they're doing good work they're
there for them to be better to be more
well thought of to
gain some level of popularity or
prestige and so if we
could just be more about others and less
about us
i think that's one of the biggest things
that i would love to see us
as a people try to do the second thing
is
to your position in life to be
optimistic
to see the glass half full with all of
the crazy stuff going on in our world
today
i mean frankly i don't watch the news
because
i can't listen to those who are talking
about how much bad
there is and how much struggle we're
having i want to see
the best in people and the best in our
society and so
being less about ourselves more about
others and being more positive about
what the future can be and less negative
about what the present might be
are two key things for me so how do we
learn that how do we learn to be less
selfish i mean you can't just go up to
somebody and say hey be less selfish
well no again it's a process it's a
journey
sometimes i ask people to ask himself
two or three questions
when they see somebody in crisis what
are your first two or three thoughts
and then why are those your first two or
three thoughts
and what are two or three thoughts you
could replace those two or three
with so just practical questions and can
i now flip a switch
and make myself think something else the
next time i see somebody in that same
situation
yeah how have you taught these lessons
to your daughters
well practical expression's the biggest
way they've just seen me live it out
people want me all the time to come in
and teach them how to do what we do and
i say well better ways for you to come
hang out with us for a week
because i can do a seminar but this is
really something you have to see and
feel
and so my girls grew up with homeless
folks sitting at our dinner table
with girls i picked up from jail that
morning that i got arrested for
prostitution that night
they're telling us their story and i
have to dismiss the girls from the
breakfast table because the graphic
nature of the conversation
they've seen me out in the middle of the
street in the night rescuing somebody
who's odd
so i think it's critical that leaders of
corporations and businesses expose their
people to
the world outside the walls of that
corporation
intentionally not just because they're
going to run into it but what's our
intentional effort
so just practical expression of it and
the living out of those
things daily my girls they just
naturally gravitate to it
after they have seen the expression of
it and seen the positive things that can
come out of it when you think back about
your life
before city of refuge who is your mentor
it is my dad primarily i mean he was a
pastor he was a missionary
he would go and speak places and come
home and mom would say
what was your honorarium because she
managed the bills and he goes i don't
know there was somebody there that
needed it more than us so i gave it to
them
we always had people living in our homes
growing up so we got a call one night
about being time we get a call from this
lady and she says hey
her husband's name is roger he's drunk
and he's beating me and the kids again
can he come get us
he's in the basement right now dad
immediately gets in the car goes and
picks them up brings them over they're
in the house
it's 11 or 12 o'clock at night we're all
in the bed roger calls and says
cecil i'm coming to get my wife and kids
and he says well you can't have them and
he goes well i'll kill you and take them
and so they literally woke us up in the
middle of the night told us my two
brothers
some cousins were with us we're all
under the bed in the back bedroom
scared to death at 10 11 12 years old
the guy shows up on the front porch he
and dad are in a heated
and all of a sudden he just starts he
fired a gun 21 times through our house
and dad's wrestling with the guy and
he's threatening to kill us all
and at the end of the day the wife and
children stayed with us and roger went
to jail
and so sort of what i was exposed to
early on in life and we've had our own
experiences of that here
in 23 years and someone is looking down
and looking after your family
because i mean oh well yeah i mean you
know we're
we're not shy about the fact we're
faith-based organization i believe
providential
care was all over that and still over me
today absolutely
what makes you scared my answer is
probably strange
what makes me scared is not doing what
i'm supposed to do
we've been here 23 years we're broken
into 34 times we've had vehicles
stolen i've been in superior court with
guys that wanted to kill me
probably to my detriment i'm not much
afraid in the streets
i am afraid of not fulfilling what i
believe is my god-given purpose and i'm
afraid of not inspiring
others to do that as well so i always
want to make sure when i share that i
present this in such a way that is
invitational
and not condemnational i'm not saying to
people
you're bad because you're not doing what
we do or what other people in the world
do i'm inviting people
to see if they can step out of their
comfort zone and see if life can't have
a little more color and flavor to it
well you are living your purpose today
my friend i am so inspired
unfortunately you're one of a kind i
wish there were many of you
the lessons that you have learned from
the work that you do i think have
application to all of us in our lives
and i know just from the time i get to
talk to you even just now i'm
going through my head of things i can do
better well thank you
thank you for all the good you do to
make people feel better about getting up
every day and going to work and coming
home happy and fulfilled you are magic
my friend thank you so much
thank you simon
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and if you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other